welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in guardians of the galaxy vol 2
teaches us to never meet your heroes
because they might give you and everyone
you know space cancer as we saw in vol 1
director James Gunn loves to hide all
kinds of secrets in the production
design soundtrack and in this case bones
I made some headway with the long-lost
volume 1 Easter egg so you know I'm all
boond up for volume 2 praising don't
care let's do this only 2 opens with
Peter Quill's mother Meredith and his
father ego once again the awesome mix
soundtrack tells Meredith's whole story
brandy you're a fine girl by
lookingglass actually has some bummer
lyrics about a sailor who abandons his
lady just like ego admits to doing -
Meredith later brandy you're a fine girl
what a good wife you would be my life my
love my lady is the suit cares so little
for Meredith that he whistles this song
her favorite song as he takes a piss he
goes Ford Mustang - King Cobra has the
same color scheme that Peter will later
use for the mulatto and as they drive
into the DQ there's a cameo by James
Gunn's late dog Oh dr. whiz Levon Spears
who also cameoed in volume 1 the
Guardians now take down an Abba Liske
pest on the sovereign because according
to gun it feeds on their nuclear fuel
quill uses a modified 1977 Mattel
handheld electronic football game as a
sensor and he argues with Gamora
overusing her sword and thought your
thing was a sword which she ends up
having to use since this is an
interdimensional beast power pole
Godslayer once again here quill insists
on diegetic musical accompaniment from
his mom's awesome mix mr. blue sky which
is an ironically sunny tuned for the
hellish battle baby groots blissful
dance echoes quills or boney wacky and
opening dance in volume 1 James Gunn
never cuts he contributes his own happy
dance mocap - and he spent two years on
Groot singing in the rain here because
as this film's unlikely guru later
explains there are two types of beans in
the universe
those are dance and those who do not gun
said the sequel is all about family
versus ego not just the literally go but
how toxic self-centeredness
poisons the tribe Groot freezes in front
of Drax just as they did at the end of
only one because he knows Drax and his
wife were non dancers he doesn't want
that divide to alienate him from his
brother Groot Cher's duet moments with
each guardian until Drax crashes
everything Groot stays mad at him
throughout the film until the very end
where he shows his true love for him the
genetics obsessed
Aisha asks about quills father an
unorthodox genealogy a hybrid that seems
particularly reckless will begins this
movie thinking genetic bloodlines
dictate what family means that is an
egotistical view rocket seals annual axe
batteries are buleria batteries
these batteries are a key device for
plot and theme they parallel the way ego
uses quill as a battery you'll have to
learn by spending the next thousand
years as a battery dhondu later tells
the battery stealing rocket I know who
you are boy because you're me and
battery quill was an asset that yondu's
stole from ego and as ego implanted
cancer in Meredith's brain rocket and
Groot implant these explosive batteries
in egos brain poetic justice and they
used baby groots ability to squeeze into
small places the same way that yondu
used skinny quill fourth even it's all
connected
quill shirts translates to gears shift
with these smaller words beside it dust
cement stone and ash underneath it all
says at eniac galaxy invention for carat
ENIAC VIII films wardrobe designer and
my favorite detail in this film just
noticed it in the most recent rewatched
a full beat before Drax sneaks up on
quill you look closely you can see Drax
blending in invisibly behind good morn
emulous as they pass perfectly still so
great the pilot through a quantum
asteroid fields icon and Empire Strikes
Back except these asteroids disappear
and reappear similar to the trippy
quantum mechanics that the Avengers used
to hijack time travel an in-game quill
and rockets family destroying ego match
fittingly ends with the arrival of
capital e ego his ship is designed to
reflect an egg-like mark ship from Mork
and Mindy this film is filled with
reproductive imagery from egos
seed in the opening scene to the way he
impregnates this egg vessel to the sperm
e shape at later takes and the fact that
he uses egg-shaped tableaus to tell his
horny life story about how he's trying
to impregnate the whole universe now the
jump point in this movie is a hexagonal
portal and four men on the MCU it's
known as the universal neural
teleportation Network it's first
introduced here in this movie and then
it becomes the MCU superhighway
thanks for the world building gun and
the moment they enter bare hearts
atmosphere the Milano bursts into flames
from atmospheric friction along with
Drax
Bearheart is a planet for the whole
comics and here gun gives it these
coordinates as with all the locations in
both of his films in my Volume one
breakdown I explained how the long-lost
missing Easter egg is actually a secret
message encoded into the coordinates
discovered way back by youtuber MT and
years later still being deciphered by
the guardians of the galaxy discord
community their translation for the
volume 1 coordinates is something about
Meredith quill which Gunn has graded as
70% correct their latest volume 2
coordinates translation is by a medical
clinic 89p13 half world cage C mission
plan is to seek IO Wyndham built math
he's a smart attack ICBM so the theory
is that rocket who is Zander ID number 8
9 P 13 will have his mystery origin
revealed in volume 3 as the genetic
experiment from hack world of Herbert
Wyndham the High Evolutionary from the
Marvel Comics all may be to resemble an
earth raccoon and for some ICBM related
plot I'm thinking maybe the one Ant Man
and the wasp foiled in the 80s moments
earlier in this film rocket said we
cybernetic be engineered the pilot of
space cranium later Yonder says I know
them scientists what made you never give
a rat's ass about you I'm cereal yes
someone built this trash panda I think
we will find out who here quill tells
nebula you know you'd think an evil
supervillain would learn how to properly
lie beneath a ward inning game nebulas
father
Thanos never lies the father as many
things Liars not much and in this movie
ego doesn't lie he just gradually
revealed more and more of the truth
until we hate him onto contracts via the
Ravagers hangout that they actually all
arrived from an in-game how are the duck
cameos again here and in the on dues
room in the background there's a picture
of wall Russ
who accompanies rocket and Groot in the
comics yondu fights with DiCaro bored
you'll never you're the hordes of
freedom when you die I do and the colors
of a gourd will never flash over your
grave mad because yondu traffic's kids
Leon who actually did it as a merciful
move seeing Don do was outcast because
he's too proud to admit he kept quill
out of that familial love ego tells
quill yondu kept you I have no clue as
to why yeah ego definitely couldn't
imagine anyone who would want to keep a
son without an evil use for that son
again the Guru speaks thought yondu was
your father because he was this daddy
Gamora reminds quill how he would tell
people his dad was David Hasselhoff
later quill describes the hafiz this
he's a singer and actor for more it's a
really famous guy
hello he says singer first hop of course
cameos later and in the credits he sings
lead on composer Tyler Bates guardians
Inferno song with gun singing backup as
group splits up quill plays Fleetwood
Mac's the chain a song recorded when
that band was going through some nasty
divorces so by leaving with ego quill is
breaking the chain of his real family
mantas puts ego to sleep explaining I
can make a stubborn person compliant but
I'm mostly using to help my master sleep
he lies awake at night thinking about
his progeny or how he killed them an
infinity war mantis uses this they move
on Thanos who in that moment dreams
about how he killed his daughter Gamora
on two egos planet where we hear George
Harrison's my sweet lord a song about a
more intimate relationship with God
which mixes both Hindu and
judeo-christian names for God reflecting
how ego is a father to countless races
these domes look kind of like the tops
of skulls maybe a hint of the deadly
truth of egos dead kids creeping up from
below this utopian surface egos wardrobe
design also embodies this idea on a
surface gold and Leicester but
underneath
cold deliberate clockwork to move on to
the next cog ego says he's the celestial
originating as a brain flirtin in space
this is all based on the theoretical
physics concept of the Boltzmann brain
which proposes that in a chaotic
universe we are statistically more
likely to be self contained minds that
imagine our realities around us then we
are actual beings in a shared reality
which is basically a scientific
justification for the triumph of one's
ego over the tribe you all only exist
because I concede you two and the Guru
speaks again when you're ugly and
someone loves you you know they love you
for who you are
beautiful people never know who to trust
this explains where the guardians are
such a tight-knit family they're all
goofy looking broken toys pretty Marvel
heroes like Thor though constantly
betrayed
it's a beautiful idiot quill tries to
recreate his genuine chemistry with
Gamora and volume one this time with Sam
Cooke's bring it on home to me a song
that's really alerts the attempts to woo
an uninterested lady peter immaturely
compares their will they won't they
chemistry to Sam and Diane from Cheers
and we're gonna do something about this
unspoken thing between us who fails
because he's channeling ego not family I
finally found my family don't you
understand that they thought you already
had
I love how immediately after this Gamora
sees two weeds rubbing against each
other dancing in the wind and no dancing
nebula North by Northwest her sister and
the ensuing argument reveals them wasn't
nebulas competitive pride that drives
her it is family
yeah you were the one who wanted to win
and I just wanted a sister sisters find
egos corpse pile which gun recently
tweeted was filled with an identified
Easter eggs all of you were like who
corpses let Moss take a whiff
like I'm YouTube's paleontologist
Indiana bones but you know I think we
were able to find some stuff so let's do
it corpse down
okay on the boulder to the left I think
that could be a Gungan from Star Wars
you'll send a celestial lay on the right
I want to say that stitch crash laying
in the wrong universe a hole now the
close-ups of the heap show what looks
like a korbinite skull tell like the one
quill slapped on Morag invol um-- one
that's a race of beta ray bill also
shows up into Ragnarok nearby there's
some long fingers with joint similar to
the face hugger in the Alien franchise
but I have a feeling that they wouldn't
include recognizable skulls of
characters owned by other movie studios
at that time there's a set photo that
gives us a real clear look at the pile
that they used for the close-ups the one
right in the middle kind of looks like a
duck
maybe another duck world in aside from
Howard the Duck or Donald or Daisy knew
master 68 on our discord said that the
one beneath looks like Davy Jones from
Pirates movies maybe nian um from Star
Wars
he also spotted one that looks like the
rancor from Return of the Jedi along
with a curved bone similar to the one
Luke used to brace its jaws Russell on
discord thought another looks like a
Chitauri others have looked at this in
thought some looks like otter bones for
Lyla Rockets companion from his volume
ones and our screen maybe we'll learn
that ego slate or took him through the
high evolutionary's creations tying in
quill and rockets origins there's more
to this I'm gonna break this all down in
a separate video as you could tell
guardians Wellington's movie I have
watched more than once but after rewatch
number 12 and after the stack of Bones
gets too high really to get my papers a
rest with a nice audio book and this
video is brought to you by audible in
their unmatched selection of audiobooks
and other audio products with so many of
us stuck at home with libraries and
schools closed audible has stepped up to
help they launch stories audible.com for
kids and parents stuck at home to stream
lots of great stories for three they got
CS Lewis Scarlett Johansson reading
Alice in Wonderland and a whole bunch
more family-friendly stuff for free
during quarantine at story's audible.com
they also launched audible sleep a free
service with all kinds of bedtime
stories guided meditations other ways
that we can wrestle a good night of
shut-eye back from the stress monsters
and paid in all of our homes right now
they've even expanded the amount of
content available to existing members
that content includes the best selection
of audio books podcasts inaudible
originals you can't find anywhere else
their audiobook selection includes my
old favorite dress apart from Mikey
Crichton when I want to relax and forget
my troubles I just stripped away to the
tropical Isla Nublar or Sam Jackson has
given me a backrub oh my god the Raptor
ate him finally get into that game of
Thrones Stephen King or Neil Gaiman book
that you've been thinking about start
listening with a 30-day audible trial
choose one out of you a book in two
audible originals absolutely free visit
audible.com slash new rock stars or text
new rock stars to 500 500 again that's
audible.com slash new rock stars or text
new rock stars - 500 500 for one
audiobook and two audible originals
absolutely free let's jump back to
rocket taser face mutinies yondu's
loyals out the airlock
foreshadowing yondu's own death captain
going down with his true crew group
brings them workers I a call back to vol
1 there's one more thing we need to
complete the plan that guys I and Groot
reveals he hates hats because it
confuses hats for the shape of the head
I joke about how it's not really clear
whether yondu spin is or is not part of
his head in the comics bursted in the
movies
Richard Christie cameos is the ravager
who yelled his name in the credits he is
the drummer for the heavy metal band
debt rockets tablet shows an interesting
planet names Tressler holla terma
Terra and ego Terra's earth egos ego
holla is the Kree homeworld later shown
in Captain Marvel Dressler in turn are
the weird ones they show up at a
crossover comic annihilation conquest
which ties in the Guardians Adam warlock
and the High Evolutionary perhaps
another clue to Rockets origin they
blast has two fighting Cronin's the race
of Korg in the Cronin Thor killed in
dark world they also passed our man
Stanley at that time I was a federalist
best man now he's talking to Watchers
these are the overseers of the
multiverse in the Marvel comics with who
watching The Watcher hosting the
upcoming what-if series Stan's referring
to his cameo as the FedEx guy in Civil
War yes this Louie technically takes
place before Civil War but it has been
hinted by Gunn and Kevin Feige and
others that Stan could be a figure akin
to the one above all in the Marvel
Comics who transcends all of time they
arrive at ego whose planet surface now
is the face like it's conic appearance
we're in an old piece of construction
equipment yondu once used to slice open
the bank of ask of area again reference
s covariance that tentacled race that
quill admitted to hooking up with in
volume one that baked ice could've been
the mission where Peter did that ego
gives Peter a vision touching his
forehead in that same g-spot to the
ancient one to distrain
Church now Gunn has debunked the theory
that Peters mother is the capital e
eternity or lady death but he has as of
this recording left the door open to
infinity the other female entity in that
Morag art I just think Meredith must be
someone important because ego says that
Meredith was the only partner strong
enough to produce a viable heir not one
of them carried the celestial genes
until you feed her among egos mate is a
member of mantises race the actresses
sued him in this model claimed in a
sense deleted post that she played
mantises mom and gun also posted a
picture of her on his Instagram but he
clarified later that this model and
mantis are not related so it seems like
mantis it's not Peter stepsister but it
is cool how they're hooking up here but
ego is not touching her you think
doesn't want her to feel as deep dark
secrets ego reveals he gave Meredith the
tumor any forces of link to Peter to
expand like a tumor across the universe
glutton back in Missouri where we get
cameos of the guns parents and Linder
Peters grandfather from volume 1
yondu breaks the chain right there just
repeating his bits from volume 1 that
guy was a jackass rocket pulled the same
kamikaze move on ronan to volume 1 and
nebula pulls it on Thanos and Infinity
Ward you're on doing Peter float down
with a Yakka air ho hot bad pop no I
like how Michael Rooker keeps his heels
together like Mary Poppins rocket gets
his hands on a big gun and gives us a
yeah back yeah yeah and ego taunts
greater meaning can life possibly have
to offer
yondu tells Peter that the way he
controls his arrows with this heart and
the chain plays once more as Peter
flashes back with Wyatt Olaf returning
as young Peter Peter chains himself to
his real family not the toxic ego or as
yondu says in his own words may have
been your father boy but he wasn't your
daddy rocket knew the sacrifice was
coming I can only afford to lose one
friend today that's also why it hurts
Rockets so much an infinity war an end
game when he loses all of his friends in
the same day yondu's corpse is decorated
with his frog trinket and the troll doll
from volume 1
he's also got US military service
patches Air Force and Army captain's
bars the National Defense Service Medal
an army ribbon for Good Conduct and an
Air Force missile maintenance bag
okay a pocket rocket given to
specialists who have worked with guided
missiles and ICBMs very fitting for
yondu's mastery over his guided arrow
sometimes that thing you're searching
for your whole life it's right there by
your side all along you don't even know
it the family lesson learned by all the
Guardians including these sisters who
exchanged a hug even a little pat from
nebula crackling gives quill yondu xun
replacing the broken meredith awesome
mix the next song on this playlist was
Cat Stevens father and son so this was a
song yonder was listening to as they
returned to save Peter I'm crying your
crane and yondu's sacrifice earns him
the ravager funeral he was previously
denies de Caro Gord returns along with
the other Ravager captains including
Charlie 27 Aleta aboard in the comics
it's two cars sepsis er that shares a
Starhawk identity with them the
confusing and the post-credits scene
they will be joined by Martin X Kruger
who's a limb sorcerer in the alternate
universe sorcerer supreme and Miley
Cyrus and a vocal cameo as mainframe
another post-credits scene shows crag
land operating the Yakka arrow another
shows Aisha and Adam warlocks golden
birthing pod retconning though organic
one wrong one Adam is Ayesha's
genetically perfect male counterpart in
the comics plays a big role in the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline but he's
left out of those movies but he will be
back there is also a scene with Peter in
teenage groups on roots walls of some
scroll lettering there's the word maple
on the right side wall maybe some other
tree grits and - and on the wall by the
door
the scroll letters for you gun actually
just recently confirm that 50 of the IM
groups in this movie are f-bombs
maybe that includes some of the names
and the credits where you can see I am
Groot showing up at again again this
also came as my Cosmo more volume on the
Hoff shows up Howard the Duck Peter's
grandpa and Jeff Goldblum as the
Grandmaster who will make his debut two
movies later in thor ragnarok breakdown
coming next week and then this jokey
disclaimer about trees and raccoons
not being harmed - but not the handlers
but back to the closing images the
colors of o gourd take the shape of an
arrow to honor yondu's Yakka arrow his
sacrifice helped this family conquer
their poisonous egos Groot embraces Drax
Peter and Gamora acknowledged their
unspoken thing and a single tear rolls
down from rocket over Cat Stevens final
words
the words of a son letting go of his
father now of course the daddies on the
mines here are Peters ties to ego and
yondu and gomorrah nebulus ties to
Thanos but playing the lyric of a rock
it's interesting because his paternal
chain is still a mystery
is it the High Evolutionary was the
evidence of the boneyard time will tell
but this is the face of a trash panda
who still needs to break the chain with
a daddy somewhere to silence his ego and
to join his true family he knows he has
to go join our future infinity saga
watch alongside discord by becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash new rock
stars follow me on instagram and twitter
at EA boss follow new rockstars and
subscribe to help us call stranger
danger on a grown man in the school
bathroom with minors I mean before I met
Tony
[Music]